okay hey everyone it's Mike BOS here
from order flows.com and this is the
orderflows market analysis for Friday
February 17
2017 um a big rally late in the session
and we'll get to that in a minute but
first a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision
Futures Trading contains substantial
risk and it's not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost
without jeopardizing one's Financial
Security or lifestyle only risk Capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk Capital
should consider trading past performance
is not necessarily indicative of future
results in this presentation I use
several tools the orderflows trader
footprint chart the fal flip the U-turn
and the
transition all right so start first in
the bonds all right this is a four range
chart and very similar to yesterday if
you remember
um we have this High here at in the
morning 746 yeah very strong negative
Delta - 1200 and you know leading up to
this High we had you know from 7:00 to
7:45 basically it's just you know stair
stepping up up up up um you know some
decent Deltas you got some buying
imbalances in there hit this High got a
ratio here 128 you have a the Divergence
with the strong negative Delta again if
you're not convinced that this high is
going to hold look to the next bar again
you got another blue number so another
bearish ratio and what do you do you run
right down into a bar met with a bullish
ratio but again you know it's that's one
bar but you know what's interesting it's
got a very small Delta of uh just 31 you
know which is kind of I don't want to
say delta neutral it's kind of neutral
in Delta analysis in as far as order
flows go you know because you know
that's a difference of basically one
trade it could go either way you know if
if there was another 33 Lots there it
would have been um negative Delta and
what do we do we continue in the next
bar you this bar turns up this bar turns
down again down negative Delta negative
Delta and you know so we went from this
high here at uh
15131 all the way down to uh you know at
840 we get down to this uh 16 level
bounced up a little bit and you know
just we went a little bit lower um you
know later in the session I mean that
was it we never tested those highs again
U I'm not saying you you would have held
it all day but you know you could have
at least got uh you know it was it was
the move right and you know the
orderflow gave it gave it away um you
know you're coming up into this High
here the only the only negative thing
about this um setup is you have this
high and look at the bar right before it
it's a positive Delta of 600 you have a
bullish number here you got uh you know
153 is the ratio right it's blue number
you got a single print here too and you
know again it's it's the Delta here is
and it's you know higher than the
previous two Deltas you know you had 73
in the bar before it 283 here so it's
getting a little bit stronger actually
but it just really flips over in here um
then falls down you know 610 but it's
met with you know this is not 295 it's
1,295 so it's you
know over over twice the uh over twice
the
amount and then it just uh again it just
Falls over right in here
so you know that was the one trade there
in the in the uh bonds all right so this
next uh this next contract I'll show you
this is soybeans um you know someone had
messaged me about this and I wasn't
watching it but I had the chart open and
you know it's this High here in the
soybeans at
852 you've got you got a few things
going on up here you know you've got
this one you know it's a swing High you
got point of control at the high you've
got a ratio up there you've got a buying
and balance up on top and you know this
was this was literally you know Oly it
wasn't uh was at the high of the day no
um you know early I mean overnight you
had the high but it was this nice swing
High during the main session during the
US session and you
know people you know sometimes they get
all caught up with you know the high of
the day um you know you're looking for
certain things but you know what once
the you know especially for grains right
when the main session opens up you know
it's
basically you can't disregard what
happened overnight but you should also
respect what are the uh us session highs
and lows as well so this is a a US
session high and at that high you've got
a buying imbalance you know you got the
point of control right at the top and
then you just start coming down you know
it's I don't want to say you know the
the Delta is changing in here because
it's still quite strong here it's 341
253 then 39 30 and 4 but you know it's
starting to pick up down here you're
getting some you know ratio here ratio
here so you're indicating some price
rejection this is actually U one of my
indicators given given a sell
there that's the price rejector I
believe and and look at that I mean you
know you have all this time in here to
getting short around this 1039 1038 and
a half area and it just you know it just
Builds on itself goes down into the lows
take out the lows um you know down into
this
1031 area so you know then this just
picks up again uh you know bit bit later
this is the Delta surge given a byy
there so um you know the same things
apply whether you're looking at uh
soybeans whether you're looking at bonds
whether you're looking at e- mini
snps okay five years real quick here um
you know similar to the bonds you have
this High here at 748 you got the
Divergence you got a ratio up there um
you got some nice imbalances in here and
it just Falls over again this one is a
little bit different than the bonds in
that the bar before it
had a negative Delta you so you're
coming up here with a strong positive
Delta 1500 the negative 800 you're still
going up you're still going up though
get up here right at the high boom it
all changes and and it just Falls over
,700 here -500 - 2,000 you got three
ratios in a row blue number blue number
blue number I would have liked to pull
back um you know you got to pull back
here it's still a red bar you visually
what I'd like to see is a green bar but
you got to pull back up to this point of
control ideally I'd like to get a pull
back in between here to be getting short
you did a bit later um almost almost 40
minutes later get a pull back up in here
um before continuing down but really you
I mean the the the the signal was up in
here in this bar you don't have to wait
for this three in a row um you could be
getting short in here very easily and
you know you could have
got you know anywhere between uh you
know 118 even 117 31 and A2 all the way
down here to at least you know the the
30 area that's um you know eight eight
or nine
ticks okay um yeah I'm not going to show
the three range footprint chart today
because it it it was pretty quiet most
of the morning actually um and we got
that nice late rally when I say quiet I
mean you know this is a three range bar
chart and you know the cash open is in
here around you know we open up around
2238 you know up to 42 so it's basically
trading in a four-point Range you know
most of most of the morning and late in
the session we got that rally uh this is
the TR U-turn um you again you know you
should really be Keen in you know after
seven ideally After Cash open yeah you
got a little sell here so I mean these
yeah they work but again it's at that
time when I'm not really necessarily
looking to trade so in here is you know
the cash open and you get a small move
here and it comes back up this one goes
sideways these two sort of go nowhere
then late in the session you got that
big rally um you know it doesn't look
that good on this chart but um you I'll
show you a dow chart in in a second
right um this is the E mini 987 tick
chart again you know after 8:30 it
wasn't much before that nothing um 8:30
got a sell here again they made that
moved down and then turned around came
back up to your entry and then you know
late here you got this sell this was uh
around 12 just just before just right on
12ish was a little sell then it came
right back up and then spent the rest of
the day rallying
um I said you know it's it's you know
today was during the session was um you
know pretty pretty
uneventful and you know the euro
currency this is a 987 tick chart no no
trades on the transition you know so
it's not like I had a big losing trade
and I just don't want to show you
there's nothing nothing happening
there you know in why I mean people will
get all you know
panty in a bunch saying oh you know it's
not working well the reason there's no
it looks like it's not working is there
was nothing in the order flow uh kicking
off that you know is given it um you
know giving it a giving it a signal you
know it reads the order flow and if
there's nothing in the order flow it's
not going to give you know it's not
going to give a signal um so let me just
find some other charts pull them up
here just because there there's nothing
there it doesn't mean you know that that
there was anything to trade around you
know sometimes there's nothing happening
you know in in the
market uh this is crude oil uh April now
I'm on got my April chart
here uh earlier nothing here you got to
buy didn't you I like it to not do this
first and then make that move I don't
like you know getting a Buy Signal here
then it comes down a bit and then makes
the move up and you know couple of the
sell didn't you know these two didn't
work but again you know let the market
try and Lead You into the position know
here at least it started down you know
I'm more willing to I'll say willing you
know
I you know one thing I don't really talk
about is you know my my some of my
trading Styles you know I like to let
the market move in the direction you
know take me into it take me into a
trade just because boom there's a signal
here it's not like oh I'm getting short
immediately on the next bar no you know
I like to see the market start moving in
my direction like here it doesn't right
it's you know this is this is the low of
this bar and then the next bar it just
rallies right so okay you know I'm fine
to hold off and and not take that trade
you know I'm not like a person that's
going to take every signal you know I I
need to see the market start you know I
have the confirmation in the order flow
that's what these signals do they give
me that confirmation then I want to see
it moving in that direction right before
I start getting short if it doesn't at
all and it just rallies on me you know
this one here is actionable you could be
looking to take it this one no
definitely not um same same here with
this one right you have the high of this
bar we haven't even gotten above this
High you know so you shouldn't be
looking to get long in here yeah I mean
sure people can say well you get a
better better entry but it's just going
to come down here and stop you out just
like here you know you're getting short
and say oh I could get short up here
yeah but then you're going to get right
you know stopped out would you rather be
getting in you like here and getting in
down
here and at least have you know the
trade go in your favor rather than it
never go in your favor and just
constantly be against you till till it
hit your stop I much rather you know
give it the chance you know go in my
favor start moving and then you know
come up to my stop and stop me
out um what else I
got trying to find my uh hero
currency chart another one that's the
footprint chart um I want to show you
guys the it's easier for me to just talk
about some of these indicators on on a
bar chart rather than uh on the
footprint chart because you know it's
just it's reading the
uh it's reading the order flow for me um
I mean I could talk about the order flow
but on a one minute chart it's it's
moving pretty fast it wasn't very good
today um in the euro
currency I wish I could say it was but
um yeah it was it wasn't it struggled um
you know losing trade here but again it
never went in your favor so you know
getting a short signal here you should
be looking for the market to start
trading down not just immediately get
short then boom it stops you out let
just like here yeah this one started to
and then it came down and then stopped
you know stopped you out just like these
you know you sort of get these little
false starts this one barely gets like
one tick above so I I don't know if I
would have been taking it I mean you
can't just use you know one tick
breakout you know give it a few
ticks
um you know these two boom boom
nothing come in if if you want to be you
know quick on the trigger and say hey
yeah I'm going to get in right here as
soon as this bar closes you know you can
be getting in a bit prematurely and
again look we never even get above this
level here we just always it just hangs
there stays below I mean it looks like
in this bar it looks like it's going to
just pop up rally up to the upside would
have been nice like the snps but you
know the market uh had had other other
thoughts in mind that it didn't you know
wasn't willing to make that move
um what is this okay this mini da this
is the flip okay so again you here it's
giving you a short signal here in the
next bar it just comes down you like one
or two ticks and then rallies back up
and spends all this time it then makes
the move again you know you want to
ideally let it start to you know go in
your go in your direction right rather
than just immediately get short and then
get stopped out up here you know that
that's not what you want to do in in
trading you know you want to just take
every single signal boom fast as soon as
it happens I mean you know part of being
a system Trader is that I don't consider
myself a systems Trader you know not by
any stretch of the imagination you know
I I I consider myself more of I hate to
say flow Trader but you know I like to
go with the flow of the market you know
let me let it take me into the position
okay so this this will be the last chart
here this is the mini da this
morning okay so anyway um this is uh
what time is this is 8:00 this
morning again you know mini do you
should be waiting for the cash Market to
open which is 8:30 in in here and again
you know here right you get the high of
this bar and you can see the next bar it
starts rallying that's making the move
right so notice it doesn't pull back all
the way down here and then make the move
you know what you want is the move to
happen relatively quick and now it's
happening here you see boom boom boom
boom right so this is you know this is a
nice trade you know are you willing to
give up that's what I often say to
people I don't say the second part but I
feel I have to you know are you willing
to give up a little bit of your entry to
to be you know having a good trade right
a
good a winning trade you know would you
rather you know this is the bar right
this is the bar that's giving you your
uh your entry you know saying hey you
know it could be this could be a
potential low area okay if this is going
to be the low right you know these are
reversal um indicators in the order FL
if it's going to be the low then it
needs to start trading higher right you
don't expect it to go lower then go
higher you I'm looking for the low to be
in here so when it starts giving you
those signs in here that yeah okay we're
Above This the high of this bar nice x
amount of ticks yeah now the now we're
going to go higher and then you do right
that's that's what you want I don't know
how else to explain it to people so they
can understand it but um you know let
the market move in your direction again
you know if this is going to be a swing
low then you shouldn't be coming down
here right you should be staying above
here and and you are in the next bar
next two bars you how many ticks above
there um you know this is 25 you're
trading 28 up here okay it's safe to get
long right and you're getting long at 28
it goes all the way up you know up to 50
here you get a a sell but again you know
what does it do if this is going to be a
swing High you got to start trading
lower not back not back
up what else you got again here yeah it
started to work out but but then you
know it turned back up in here and you
know came back down that one would have
you probably would have broken even this
one maybe took a broke even or a small
loss there's no shame in taking small
losses I mean that's what you want to do
as a Trader here you know it doesn't
really happen you know here it pops up a
little bit but by the time it pops up it
just comes right back down again you
have to low of this bar it never gets
below this level here at 35 why are you
getting short you're getting short at 36
you know that's not what you want to do
you want let the market start going in
your
direction um then here later in this
session here this is around the 65 area
so you know let it get up to you know
the 68 area and you know it does it
comes back down though unfortunately you
know probably would have you know
depending on how tight your stop is um
you know if it's 10 ticks maybe not if
it's n eight ticks probably would have
um but you know it gives you another
entry in here you you could be getting
long in here and you hopefully got
something back
shouldn't be sitting through these bars
though um you should be trailing your
stop you got to remember it's right
ahead of the cash open you know I'm not
saying you would have bought it here and
sold it up here I I think you should
have been watching it and any sign that
it's starting to turn you should be
cutting it you know don't let it come
all the way back down here and cut it
for you know a break even or a loss you
should be trailing it up here and get
out at you know if you're getting in at
you know 60 you know even 70 worst case
scenario you know no no shame in getting
out with five tick winner here at 75 at
least you got something out of the trade
rather than they come down here to 70
and stopping you out and at at nothing
so thanks for watching this video to
tell learn more about orderflow trading
and the software use in this video visit
my website uh www. orderflows
docomo um subscribe to my YouTube
channel you know just click on the
little subscribe button you'll see it
down in here on the video and at least
you be notified of you know new videos
that come out I try to do one a day if
possible um you know time permitting but
um you know again thanks for watching
this and to learn more go to my website
orderflows decom so thanks and hope to
see you on the inside